nous sommes avec louis keumayou la
présidente du club
de la formation de la formation
africaine merci beaucoup lui d'être avec
nous alors est-ce que ses voeux à la
presse vont marquer le retour d'emmanuel
macro face aux journalistes parce que
l'on sait qu'il est très discret qu'il
n'aime pas trop cet exercice est
dernière meilleur il me l'avait pas fait
je pense que ça va déjà signifié que on
est en campagne pour les municipales
donc il est important pour lui d'avoir
de bonnes relations avec les
journalistes qu'elle soit factice ou
réelle
le fait est qu'il a besoin aujourd'hui
des journalistes qu'il sera important
dans le cas de la campagne qui s'annonce
et dans lequel sur tous les mouvements
sociaux qui continue kim qui ne se sont
pas arrêtés il serait bon qu'ils aient
au moins la capacité lui d'expliquer sa
politique est d'expliquer aux français
ce qu'ils envisagent de faire pour que
pour tenir compte à la fois de leurs
revendications mais également pour
justifier les réformes qu'il a requis la
peine de mener du pays c'est vrai que
nous sommes dans un contexte social très
tendu depuis maintenant pratiquement
deux ans on se souvient de la crise des
déchets les jeunes qui a commencé le 17
novembre le gouvernement qui a peut-être
joué au pourrissement aujourd'hui c'est
un petit peu le même schéma qui se
reproduit avec cette mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites
est-ce que vous pensez que
le président va peut-être expliquer
jusqu'au bout ce qui l'attend ce
gouvernement devant les journalistes
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il aura à coeur
de rassurer les français sur le fait que
ce qu'il fait est bon pour le pays est
bon pour un équilibre budgétaire du pays
et pour cela il a besoin des
journalistes ne peut pas à lui tout seul
comme au début il expliqué s'adresser
directement aux français sans passer par
les relais que sont les journalistes
donc il en a besoin et c'est tant mieux
pour la presse parce que c'est le rôle
des journalistes aussi par moments de
pouvoir avoir la parole à la fois des
officiels mais également à celle de la
population et de servir de trait d'union
entre les deux en jouant son rôle bien
sûr qui est celui de critiquer quand
c'est nécessaire et de dire que ça va
bien quand quand c'est le cas également
la dernière fois qu'il est venu almagro
s'est adressé aux français c'était lors
de la nouvelle année pour présenter ses
voeux
l'exercice est différent devant les
journalistes l'exercice est différent
oui parce que non seulement il vient
voit les journalistes pour leur parler à
eux et pas à la population
mais c'est également un exercice de
calinothérapie où il va essayer
d'expliquer aux journalistes que c'est
pas parce que j'ai eu du ddr ou que je
vous ai ignoré au début que je ne sais
pas que vous êtes là je sais que vous
êtes lake par moment j'ai besoin de
votre concours pour atteindre mes
objectifs
donc je viens vous parler et j'espère
que vous retranscrire est ce que je vous
dirais telles que je les dis ou en
restant fidèle à l'expression qui a été
la mienne je pense que c'est un exercice
dans lequel il a besoin des journalistes
et où les journalistes reprennent leur
vraie place dans le traitement de
l'information
la france est actuellement 32e au
classement mondial de la liberté
de la presse mais on a vu récemment
plusieurs journalistes qui ont été
convoqués notamment par la dg ainsi
d'autres qui ont été prises à partie
aussi pendant les manifestations des
gilets jaunes
est ce que c'est un thème qui va être
abordée selon vous par le président de
la république
je ne pense pas qu'il l'aborderait
frontalement qu'il le fera publiquement
ce qui est certain c'est que depuis
quelques années les violences envers les
journalistes ont pris une forme très
inquiétante
en france il s'agit pas seulement des
violences physiques que nous voyons
aujourd'hui il s'agit également du
secret des journalistes dans le
traitement de l'information qu'on a
voulu sous nicolas sarkozy
abolir alors que pour nous c'est quand
même un élément très important dans le
travail il ya toutes les enquêtes qui
ont été menées qui obligeait les
journalistes à dévoiler leurs sources
ce qui n'est pas du tout en conformité
avec le code d'éthique auxquelles sont
soumis les journalises on qui a tout
cela qui est aujourd'hui sur la table et
le président en dehors de ce qu'il dira
officiellement aura probablement une
rencontre et ses services surtout oran à
coeur d'expliquer aux journalistes qu'
on ne vous en veut pas par rapport à la
manière dont vous travaillez
mais c'est trop gros c'est trop gros il
ya eu beaucoup de dédain il ya eu
beaucoup de marginalisation de la part
de certains journalistes
quand on n'est pas dans le courant qui
plaît à la république en marche ou à
emmanuel macron on reçoit pas
d'accréditation on n'est pas invité aux
événements ont fait pas partie des
poules pour le traitement de
l'information et on ne reçoit pas
forcément les images dont ça fait
beaucoup de choses et je m'en méfie
d'ailleurs inquiétée une fois on parle
beaucoup du sentiment anti français
aujourd'hui qui en train de monter sur
le continent africain
mais combien de fois le président macro
s'est il adressé aux journalistes
africains pour leur expliquer sa
politique pour leur expliquer ce que la
france fait dans ces pays là il n'y a
pas eu de rendez vous de ce type
et donc quand il n'ya pas de paroles
forcément les gens spéculent et il peut
aller très loin dans leur spéculation y
compris en entretenant cette espèce de
sentiment anti français
et puisqu'il y aura ce sommet afrique
france qui va se tenir
la suggestion qui avait été fait de la
part du club la formation africaine
c'était qu'il y ait une rencontre avec
les journalistes africains
pour faire une espèce de bilan et tracer
des perspectives et qui et pourquoi pas
à une rencontre pendant le sommet au
cours de laquelle on irait plus loin
dans la compréhension de la politique
africaine de politique française en
afrique cela on a reçu une fin de non
recevoir
et ça correspond à peu près au profil
que le président à mâcon jusqu'à présent
à dresser de lui dans ses rapports avec
les journalistes sont toujours en
retrait d'être en retrait est ignorée
c'est pas que d'être retrait seulement
c'est à dire que si c'est leur presse et
passifs mais c'est très actif parce que
non seulement on est en retrait mais on
ne vous accepte pas on ne vous parle pas
on ne vous reconnais pas votre statut du
journaliste et au nord où on ne nous
permet pas d'exercer votre métier dans
les règles et avec les facilités qui
accompagne cet exercice des voeux à la
presse que nous allons suivre
bien évidemment cet après-midi en tout
cas merci beaucoup oui que mayo d'avoir
été sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes présidence du club de
l'information africaine merci merci